when Hardin passed up that seven foot
shot a moment ago
almost a turnover and bead falls to the
court bodies littered on the hardwood
here
Brown down going to be the fifth foul
against Brown yeah now listen
Michelle already used his challenge is
that correct yes yeah
oh wow oh gosh
and that was
accidental that did not look intentional
by any means just looking for a spot to
land
and that had to have hurt
Grant Williams
bloodied right now being tended to by
the athletic training staff for the
Boston Celtics
I mean
man are his teeth in place wow I cannot
believe they are oh all of the weight of
Joel embiid coming down on his head
[Applause]
it's 280 pounds oh my gosh landing on
you
get my needle
[Music]
brother nope for the ball yeah